our local resorts try and meet the  increasing customer demand  they're really still trying to hire for  all these open positions  for example tomorrow station casinos is  holding a hiring event over at boulder  station  goes from 8 until 7. and there are two  others this week as well wednesday out  at red rock thursday down at green  valley ranch  just head to 8newsnow.com for more  details  and fashion show mall is looking to fill  more than 300 positions  a job fair is going to be held there  next tuesday afternoon  there are positions at stores all  throughout the mall and no appointments  are required to go check out what's  available  and on the 22nd arizona charleys is  hosting a hiring event  at the decatur location from 10 until  two one thousand dollar  signing bonuses and bus passes are also  up for grabs they're trying to  fill those positions